[Music]
these LEDs are the beginning of the
internet of light they can sense light
amid light and collect energy all in one
the key is a thin film of spherical
semiconductors called quantum dots
attached to nanorods the asymmetrical
design allows them to perform multiple
functions the nana rod gathers electrons
while a shell around the dot gathers
positive charges the quantum dot takes
both to generate light switching the
voltage makes the process reverse the
dot collects light and feeds an electron
to the rod and a positive charge to the
shell ordinary spherical quantum dots
can't do this they switch between
collecting light and emitting it faster
than the human eye can see
so it looks like they're emitting light
continuously in the future screens made
from this technology could see without
the need of a camera TV screens or
electronic billboards could respond to
touchless gestures phones and tablets
could adjust to dappled light and any
two screens could communicate with each
other using Wi-Fi
since these LEDs can also collect energy
your phone could charge from whatever
light hits the screen having multi
function instead of single function
devices makes fabrication easier so far
these experimental LEDs can only produce
a single color and a small array of
pixels but improving this tech could
open up a new way for us to interact
with our devices
[Music]